vous savez comment ça s'appelle ça ça
s'appelle un vêtement de pluie quand est
ce qu'on met un vêtement de pluie est
bien quand il pleut tout ça pour vous
dire qu'il ya des petits malins qui se
disent que même quand il fait chaud et
surtout quand il fait chaud je vais
mettre un vêtement de plus comme ça je
vais transpirer et je vais perdre du
poids alors le conseil la question du
jour est ce que courir fait perdre du
poids et bien la réponse est non à moins
d'avoir un entraînement très spécifique
très ciblé et très récurrents sinon la
course à pied qu'est ce que ça fait pas
la course à pied ça fait du bien la tête
ça fait du bien au moral ça fait du bien
au coeur à vos artères vous êtes en
bonne santé mais ça ne fait pas maigrir
ça n'a jamais fait maigrir il faut bien
vous le mettre en tête c'est juste pour
vous donner du moral et vous entretenir
mais alors encore une fois si vous
voulez vraiment maigrir fait déjà
attention à ce que vous mettez dans
votre assiette un strict les graisses
toutes les sauces et tout ça et les
quantités mais attention faites pas des
bêtises comme ça parce que tout ce que
vous allez gagner en mettant un vêtement
de pluie pour hyper transpirer et bien
tout ce que vous allez gagner c'est un
bon malaise de déshydratation sur le
bord de la route et on viendra pour
ramasser ça c'est pas cool
à bientôt pour de nouveaux concerts en
ligne